Film Courage: How often would you say a screenwriter’s
first draft is their final draft?
John Truby, Author and Instructor: Never.
But it brings up I think an important point
which is that the tendency for many writers
is to think that because writing is rewriting
(the classic phrase that everybody says),
they take the approach that go ahead and write
the first draft, make mistakes, feel free
to make mistakes, because you can fix it later.
This is a very dangerous approach.
And one that seems to be a good idea at the
time but is actually the makings of a disaster.
And the reason for that is that it means the
writer is not doing their structural work
up front, their preparation.
In any craft before you actually execute that
art form, you need to do the prep work up
front.
In story, it is figuring out the structure.
This is why when I was talking about on a
television staff you don’t get to write
the first draft of the script until every
story beat is figured out in minute detail
and the show runner signs off on that.
That’s because they know on television from
experience working under tremendous time pressure
that a lot of times (most of the time) it
doesn’t get fixed in rewrite.
Whatever big structural mistakes you make
in the opening draft are then much more difficult
to fix.
I use the metaphor of concrete.
When you write that first draft of the script,
that script, that story, hardens into concrete
in your mind.
And now it’s more difficult to go back into
it, break up that concrete and make the kind
of major structural fixes that will give you
a better script.
That’s the kind of work you want to do before
you write it as a script.
And that’s why I put so much emphasis on
doing your character work, doing your plot
work (especially emphasizing the 22 building
blocks because that gives you that sequence
of your story before you write it into a script.
And one last point about this.
When I do story consulting, I much prefer
someone not send me the screenplay, that they
send me the scene list.
The sequence essentially of the 3 by 5 [index]
cards.
Because I can much more quickly figure out
what’s wrong with this story when it’s
simply in the scene list than I can when it’s
embedded in that concrete in the actual script
and there is all of this undergrowth (this
brush) that is hiding what’s really wrong
in all of this dialogue.
I don’t need that dialogue.
I just need to know the story list.
Everything comes from making that story work.
And that you’ve got to figure out upfront
before it goes to script.